c'est de l'autre côté de la manche que
s'est déroulé il ya presque vingt ans
une arnaque qui aurait pu être le casse
du siècle de candidats de la version
britannique de qui veut gagner des
millions qui devant les caméras de
télévision ont triché au célèbre jeu le
10 septembre 2001 charles harry cinq
militaires qui participent aux jeux et à
une question de devenir millionnaire
visiblement crispés ils répondent à
après une longue hésitation et c'est la
bonne réponse devant l'angleterre toute
entière le jeune homme de 28 ans devient
millionnaire
sauf que voilà après la diffusion de
l'émission la production du jeu commence
à se poser quelques questions en
visionnant les bandes les équipes se
rendent compte qu avant chaque réponse
du candidat des bruits suspects se font
entendre dans le public des spectateurs
qui tous à plusieurs reprises en réalité
dans le public se trouvaient la femme du
candidat et un complice des couennes
wittock anciens candidats de l'émission
tous les deux tout c'est pour indiquer
aux joueurs quelles réponses choisir
immédiatement la chaîne décide de ne pas
verser les gains aux joueurs et dépose
dans la foulée une plainte
les trois complices seront condamnés à
dix huit et douze mois de prison avec
une amende de 15000 livre une pièce de
théâtre intitulée quiz et même adapté de
leur histoire et ce mois ci c'est
l'adaptation télévisée de cette pièce
qui est diffusée à la télévision
britannique
et tout ça relance la faire car même 20
ans après les deux accusés crie encore à
l'innocence c'est incroyable cette
histoire la secte malouki tous et c'est
à dire que quand c'était la réponse a
été un coup réponse b deux coups elle
tout et nous revois et en revoyant donc
les images et son hymne à t'en remets
mois là on entend quelqu'un tousse et or
en tant qu'hôte quantité ils ont grillé
à mon avis le mec il a été trop bons
mots il aurait pas question d un million
de dollars personne n'aurait su il
aurait laissé passé il aurait dû gagner
je sais pas moi 48 1092 in dans le mec
il voulait pousser il va gagner un
million de dollars on l'aurait jamais vu
mais qui décomptent non méthylé qu'on
les sent quoi non il ya peu noir et à
mon avis il ya été balancé le maître
c'est possible aussi les gens dans le
public ou un truc comme ça ta ta ta
peut-être raison mais bon c'est vrai que
l histoire les folles le mec il a gagné
un million de dollars à la télé il fait
c il pleure il est au bout de sa vie
c'est c'est génial franchement ça valait
le voir oui j'en ai il y en a dans le
même temps des petits jeux on gagne pas
grand chose en france j'ai entendu ça
que y'en a qui trichent sur les ans il
ya une question avec des réponses
multiples tu prends la réponse avec la
preuve le premier chiffre de la leur fin
le 1er de l'alphabet 6 et jaune rose
vert à nos yeux une gym deux premiers
frey comme ça quelle que soit la réponse
a pas mal pas mal